[Musique]
scène de chaos à Brasilia des milliers
de partisans de l'ex-président Jair
bolsonaro à l'assaut des principaux
lieux de pouvoir saccage pillage vole et
destruction tout ça au nom du refus du
verdict des urnes et d'allégation non
fondée de fraude électorales en surface
cette tentative d'insurrection semble
calquer sur le modèle de la saut des
trumpistes contre le Capitole le 6
janvier 2021 à Washington dans les deux
cas la désinformation et la
radicalisation en ligne ont joué un rôle
crucial mais le cas brésilien a des
caractéristiques qui lui sont propres et
surmonter cette crise ne sera pas une
messe à faire pour le président Lula
les gants n'avaient pas le choix de
commencer ce premier épisode de l'année
2023 en parlant du Brésil avec ce qui
vient de se passer là-bas tellement de
choses à dire bien sûr les bolsonaristes
qui ont pris d'assaut les sièges du
pouvoir là-bas avec un beaucoup de
crainte envers la direction que prendra
le prochain gouvernement mais en toile
de fond c'est d'abord et surtout cette
histoire de fraude électoral massive qui
s'en fondement d'entrée de jeu
j'aimerais qu'on entende Gustavo Ribeiro
qui est un journaliste fondateur du
média indépendant un Brésilien reaport à
qui on a posé la question d'entrée de
jeu sur la fraude électorale massive
dans tout ce contexte là en depuis les
de la communication de bolsonaro c'est
l'effort de discréditer le système
électoral le Brésil en système électoral
Complètement électronique depuis
quasiment 30 ans bolsonaro
de façon constante il est en cause ce
système il dit même que l'élection de
2018 qu'il a gagné
largement a été fraudé qu'il aurait eu
des dizaines de millions de votes de
plus si c'était pas le fraude donc
évidemment c'est Nicolas c'est bien la
preuve que ce n'est pas directement
inspiré par Donald Trump ouais c'est
quelque chose qu'on entend beaucoup
depuis la fin de semaine dernière que
c'est inspiré par Trump tout ça mais on
voit bien son arrow c'est depuis avant
la source du capital en 2020 qu'il parle
de cette fraude massive là et au centre
de tout ça c'est les machines de vote
électronique qui sont utilisées au
Brésil parce que en fait c'est le seul
pays au monde qu'un système de votation
100% électronique et ça permet à son
arrow de jeter le doute là-dessus de
dire que bon ces machines-là peuvent
être piratés facilement et encore une
fois c'est sans preuve sans fondement il
y a le tribunal électoral du Brésil qui
surveille les élections qui est même
demandé à des pirates s'il pouvait
pirater ce système de piraté de bien sûr
ils ont trouvé
aucune faille il y a eu un Audi après la
dernière élection militaire là encore là
aucune faille trouvée aucune preuve de
fraude donc c'est entièrement sans
fondement mais est-ce que depuis 2018 là
bolsonaro continue à alimenter ce mec-là
ça repose sur rien et c'est un effet on
parle de trois quarts de ces partisans
selon des récents sondages qui n'ont pas
confiance en système électoral et si on
regarde la population totale du Brésil
c'est près de la moitié des gens qui ont
peu ou pas confiance en ces machines là
même si ces documenté le fait que c'est
sans fondement alors comment ça se fait
que ça autant d'emprise en ce moment
notamment dans les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux ils sont pour quelque
chose quand même Gustavo Ribeiro
m'expliquait justement que ces parties
d'extrême droite là et ben sonaru
lui-même ont beaucoup su profiter des
réseaux sociaux pour faire passer leur
message et bolsonaro lui-même pour se
faire élire en 2018 une fois qu'il
arrive au pouvoir le gouvernement
fédéral commence à financer de
les informations à travers des annonces
à travers le secrétariat de presse
et du coup on commence à voir aussi des
hommes d'affaires des milliardaires de
millionnaires qui financent ces réseaux
de désinformation comme avec la
désinformation là les réseaux sociaux
ont eu du mal à modérer ces discussions
là Twitter on a su cette semaine que le
nouveau patron de Twitter il en a ce qui
avait licencié l'équipe au complet de
Twitter au Brésil donc les 8 personnes
qui étaient attisées à surveiller
l'extrémisme la désinformation c'est
chose là les contenus légal au Brésil
sur Twitter ne travaillent plus
ne travailler tout simplement plus on
était licenciés donc ça ça a rajouté le
à la confusion et aux conspirations par
rapport à cette élection là et bien sûr
Nicolas plus près de nous dans le temps
lors de l'élection présidentielle qui
s'est déclinée en deux tours il y a eu
énormément de discours alimentés par les
scénariste sur l'intégrité du vote ouais
ben c'est le même genre de choses qu'on
voyait aux États-Unis donc des
questionnements sur est-ce qu'il y a des
votes qui ont été retirés à busanaro des
votes qui ont été ajoutés à Lula des
votes qui ont été transférées
qui sont magiquement apparus donc
vraiment ce même genre de discours
encore une fois sans fondement il y a de
nombreux médias de vérifications au
Brésil comme house Fatos qui ont fait
plusieurs vérifications là-dessus mais
la question c'est aussi comment est-ce
que ces réseaux sociaux là ont amplifié
la désinformation il y a le quotidien il
faut les laisser en parle au café une
enquête là-dessus entre le premier
deuxième tour qui montrait que sur Tik
Tok sur la page pour vous qui vous
recommande des contenus de manière
algorithmique qui avait énormément de
désinformations électorales qui étaient
présentées aux utilisateurs de la
plateforme et à la suite de cette
enquête là Tik Tok AJ il y avait
beaucoup moins de ce contenu là qui
apparaissait sur les pages pour vous
donc ça montre en fait que ces
plateformes là si elles veulent agir
peuvent agir peuvent avoir un certain
effet même si dans ce cas-là le contenu
était encore sur la plateforme mais il
était beaucoup moins suggéré beaucoup
moins montrer aux gens cela dit les
plateformes n'ont pas rien fait il y a
quand même des vidéos qui ont été
retirées on parle aussi du Tribunal
Supérieur électoral qui a fait passer
une règle comme quoi qu'ils avaient le
droit d'intervenir pour faire retirer
des contenus des informations
électorales des plateformes mais est-ce
que constate plusieurs journalistes au
Brésil c'est que ça a eu un effet assez
mitigé parce que quand un contenu est
retiré il y a déjà été
téléchargé repartager de nombreuses fois
soit sur la plateforme soit sur d'autres
plateformes on voit des vidéos
télécharger sur TikTok qui sera mince
sur WhatsApp sur telegram donc
globalement malgré les efforts déployés
avec énormément des infos électorales
qui a circulé pendant ces deux tours là
et même avant c'est comme on dit au
Brésil c'est essuyer un glaçon sur le
soleil parce que ce qu'on peut faire
c'est si Alexis publié un contenu faut
les cours vont intervenir sur votre
contenu et donc vous utilisez un autre
compte cinq minutes après le même
contenu là et donc c'est un peu comme je
vais du guacamo il y a on tape sur un
truc qui sort il y a un autre qui sort
et et voilà c'est c'est vraiment je suis
angoissant sur le soleil Jeff aussi ce
qui apparaît comme étant clair et
limpide c'est à quel point ce qui est
survenu le 8 janvier dernier était
préparé prémédité via ces mêmes
plateformes mais ce qu'on voit avec les
analystes politiques et les analyses des
réseaux sociaux au Brésil c'est que
personne était vraiment surpris de voir
quelque chose comme ça surgir ça faisait
des semaines que ça se traînait sur les
réseaux sociaux encore une fois comme
avec le 16 janvier aux États-Unis les
réseaux sociaux ont servi à organiser
ces événements-là ont même servi à
établir la logistique donc par exemple
non seulement il y avait des appels sur
les réseaux sociaux de se rendre pour
participer à cette action-là brésilia
mais il y avait des groupes qui avaient
été mises sur pied pour aider les gens
par exemple à trouver du transport à
trouver du logement donc la logistique
de base pour s'assurer que le plus de
gens possible puissent se rendre là-bas
prévu d'avance cette organisé il y a peu
de grandes surprises parce que quelque
chose comme ça survient ouais pas de
grande surprise mais pas plus d'actions
pour autant des autorités pour
l'empêcher quoi qu'il en soit Jeff il y
a quand même des limites non à
l'analogie au parallèle qu'on peut
tracer entre le 8 janvier brésilien et
le 6 janvier 2021 aux États-Unis bon
difficile de pouvoir de parallèle entre
les deux événements dans les deux cas on
a une foule le supporter d'un président
déchu qui tente d'investir les
institutions politiques là pour tenter
de ramener le président qui a perdu une
élection n'oublions pas les
communications entre le camp bottomeres
et le camp Trump après sa défaite le
fils de Jery bensonero Eduardo est allé
à marée Lago donc la demeure de dans
notre Trump il y aurait parlé avec dans
l'option il y avait aussi des appels
téléphoniques avec Steve Bannen qui est
un des principaux conseillers de Trump
lors de sa campagne en 2016 il y a aussi
parlé à Jason Miller un autre un autre
conseiller de Donald Trump pendant son
administration donc il y a des gens qui
voient un certain parallèle parce que ça
a été carrément organisé par le camp de
Trump pour créer un coup d'État au
Brésil il y a des limites avec ça comme
je le dis Gustavo Ribeiro ça date pas
d'hier toutes ces idées là d'un coup
d'État militaire au Brésil au Brésil on
peut pas parler de la République
brésilienne sans parler de
l'interférence militaire dans la
politique la République commence par un
coût militaire qui va déposer l'Empire
brésilien les deux premiers présidents
de la République sont des maréchaux
on a eu plusieurs cours et tentatives de
cours
donc et 21 ans du gouvernement militaire
donc
voilà c'est quelque chose qui existait
déjà mais qui a été
extrêmement
stimulé par l'ancien président pendant
plus de 4 ans mais surtout pendant on le
voit dans les affiches là c'était
carrément militaire on appelait les
militaires les ex militaires à venir
manifester l'événement on le surnommait
qui est une sorte d'appel à un événement
militaire donc ça serait faux de dire
que tout ça a été organisé des
États-Unis ou a été carrément inspiré
des États-Unis les Brésiliens ont
organisé ça même c'est une très claire
ouais et puis pour nous ce qui serait
intéressant de voir c'est jusqu'à quel
point il y aura des conséquences encore
une fois ou des restants de cet
écosystème toxique au Brésil au cours
des prochaines semaines des prochains
mois ce sera une crise difficile à gérer
pour l'ulin mais on garde un œil très
attentif là-dessus